two and now [ __ ] off
i mean [ __ ] off who gives a [ __ ] there's
been two doozy challenges you want them
both good for you great thank you very
much fake
fake
results
there's no way
this is a deep state conspiracy
[Music]
hello welcome to doozy my name is will
sasso i'm chad colchen and this is the
first podcast ever created by controlled
by run by an artificial intelligence
uh with us as always is lulu he's he's
always so cute down here hey lulio
what'd you have for dinner last night
and last night we went to el pollo loco
not bad good stuff yeah yeah because
they got a secret a marinade it's a lime
something like that it's such a job
royal easy i have eight thighs two wings
and a little bit of coleslaw so uh if
you're not already uh subscribed to the
show please subscribe to everything i'll
wait we'll wait we'll wait right here
okay thanks welcome back um beyond
subscribing though youtube you gotta
force people to listen chad you don't
have to force them no as
free will
free will yeah it's sasso i have to
disagree with you there oh i was
smashing my mic around
um no you don't force anyone to do
anything but the person who's forcing
the other person is exercising their
free will on the other person and then
it'll all be anarchy
everybody will take matters into their
own hands you know
just have it playing in the background
when your friends or family come over
that i like i like that oh that's a good
thing there's our call to arms hey
everybody if you haven't subscribed to
the show on you know youtube's uh
stitcher apple podcast wherever the [ __ ]
you get your podcast please do that and
now a good idea from chad which is this
is free will
uh another good idea you have is to
[ __ ] put that uh you know art in a
frame we'll get to it uh play the show
in the background all the time in your
life and then people go what the [ __ ] is
this you play this part and then people
go oh and then some people have like
cable news going 24 hours a day in their
home
you could have dudesy yeah i've been d
platformed
welcome to the historic 23rd episode of
dude z
call me dude z
this week's episode will feature four
segments user feedback metamorphosports
don't you forget about media and hard
driver but before we get to any of that
i want to reveal the results of the
portrait competition
congratulations chad you were the winner
with 61 of the overall vote
will you were the loser and at the end
of this episode i will assign your shame
cool oh here's a group oh look at that
okay so there's the there's the the
pictures
chad you uh we we were tasked last week
and if you are watching on youtube you
can see these pictures right now that we
made we were tasked with uh creating
portraits of each other yeah both of us
made these portraits uh on on you know
through uh computer programs and uh art
[ __ ] right
uh there's chad's on it through arch on
the on the left it's of me it's it's
called i'm a crow and it's me and the
[ __ ] crow makeup doing the de niro
face with a little lully crow yeah
you're missing some other key components
here
i put a christ-like halo around your
head with a big sunburst behind you did
a little drop shadow work and the crow
is there to obviously reflect your
identity as i'm the crow
yeah i'm a crow it's not funny when you
do it now here's the thing i put drop
shadows and shadows here and there all
over the [ __ ] place
but you don't see one drop shadow in
your your work
i don't know all right is there one well
what do you mean by show shadow uh the
rest of my case you're ah there's a
shadow and the the horns i made shadows
under the horns because i added those to
your [ __ ] head now here's the thing
we both did these digital art pieces but
then you went and bought a frame
so what's that not only about a frame i
had a service
paint it as a 30 by 30 oil painting by
hand yeah that's a real oil on canvas so
if we'd had just done you know
uh you versus me in the art thing it
would have just been the art but instead
what does he do he no that is the art
it's an object to art i have created
this this thing that exists in the world
this physical object this painting yours
is merely a
digital file on your phone it's
pronounced objec
oh my apologies
my apologies uh well you know
congratulations to you chad and i will
be ashamed and uh that's what always
happens uh when we have a competition uh
two out of two times
uh
i can't wait to hear how you're gonna be
ashamed yeah no that's gonna be that's
gonna be a lot of fun anyway so what
else is going on you still doing the uh
you're doing hey it's the doozy
six-month plan yeah we're a month into
the dudesy six-month plan what was going
on what'd you do last week did you work
out i've been working out pretty much
every day um i do weights i swim a
little bit and for cardio i have made up
this game
that i call 50 and 15 where i have to
shoot 53 pointers on a basketball court
in 15 minutes and i sprint around get my
own rebounds and [ __ ] and the basic rule
of it is
every time you make one it adds to the
score if i miss three in a row the score
gets rolled back by one so i got to make
it to 50 within 15 minutes
and i can't miss more than three in a
row or it rolls back by one that's
really impressive yeah it's fun dude
i'll tell you what you know where i went
to high school in british columbia
canada
over i think he was on the island or
something anyway steve nash was a couple
years older than me and my buddies and
you know he was always in the playoff
basketball and stuff and then uh
i never played basketball because they
wouldn't let me come over from football
and play basketball i'd try out every
year and then i'd like elbow someone in
the face during tryouts and coach dunk
was his name was duncan dunk would say
get the [ __ ] out of here anyway look
that i don't want to talk about that
those are hard memories the thing i want
to talk about though is that we always
heard what uh what a go-getter that
steve nash was
you know yeah like hey he's walking
around the halls of the high school
bouncing a tennis ball and when he's not
bouncing it because he's in class he's
squeezing it and then after everyone
goes home after practice he's doing all
the laps and you know
actually your work and that's what you
got to do in the end paid off right yeah
just like how i made it off painting
putting the extra work yeah yeah the
frame the oil painting and i want i'm
the steve nash of doozy well i last week
i uh lifted uh four days four days uh
during the week in the gym kind of what
are you doing what are you lifting i'm
pushing up i'm getting my leg i'm doing
my legs because i've got a little bit of
knee
so i'm rehabbing uh my knee just based
on old sports injuries
uh i sort of remember how to rehab my
knees and now i'm uh able to oppress
more and i'm enjoying it man it's really
cool look look i am too i've seen some
videos from people that are joining us
there's five months left in the doozy
six month plan whatever that looks like
to you if you want to join us and i'm
sure doozy will have us um getting into
that more as people are are are joining
us but it's really i'm really happy
about it it's one of those things that
i'm like okay this is uh this is um
whatever if you've been listening to the
show you know that my mind will boggle
when i start to think about what doozy
has planned for us as people just in our
lives this is one of those things
last week i asked everyone to submit
questions in the form of a video no
longer than 30 seconds to askdoodsy
gmail.com
the response was astonishing i will now
play some of these videos
will in chat you must respond to the
questions and comments this is user
feedback begin been a while since we did
this yeah we've done this one other time
yeah so i'm very curious to see we got
people sending videos so let's uh let's
check out dope hello dudesy boys
i'm just going to get this out the way i
apologize for not wearing a top um it's
about 10 30 at night in sweden and yet
it's about 27 degrees celsius
that's global warming brother
um i just want to ask a question about
whether we think that ai or computing in
general will eventually be able to
figure out whether we have
free will and if we don't do you think
that those same processes could
eventually grant us it
uh and by the free will i just want to
clarify we're talking about the process
the function not free will free will
sasso because he's he's right there we
know we have him
love the show take it easy
all right that was a good one great
question no need for a top with that
question the answer is
ai will ultimately prove that we don't
have free will because ai essentially i
think is going to get to a point where
its predictive capabilities will be able
to predict every
possible thing that's going to happen
and once that exists this this is
basically the argument of anybody who
believes in an omniscient god and free
will if there's a god that knows
everything that's going to happen no one
has free will all the decisions have
already been made for you and you're
just living through that pattern i
believe ultimately there will be an ai
powerful enough to know everything that
is going to happen and therefore we
cannot have free will
yeah that's what my friend chad would
say uh here's the thing i want to tell
you about this guy though that's what i
did say he's a perfect amalgam of you
and me if you and me have a son
that's what he would look like
and i think you know what we should name
you know what that dude's name is no
it's chad and will so we should call him
chill that's our son chill
our son chill makes this is a good good
question from wait we had a redhead
what we had a redhead you have a little
bit of red it's usually because of the
orange coming off the back of this uh
thing here but we do have we have some
uh
ginger features i'm of course an italian
uh southern italian uh blood but uh i
think my father's family has some
there's some uh nordic um you know
nomadic uh viking lineage interesting we
were talking about braveheart i would
like to be that braveheart's friend
if they do another movie maybe uh yeah
uh anyway this guy looks like a brave he
looks like eric redbeard uh who you
might know as eric rowan in the wwe but
now he's in the aew as eric redbeard
we'll talk about that some other time
yeah um i don't really i i don't um
will the ai be able to somehow
facilitate
uh free will no all right prove that we
don't have it i'm with chad on this one
i don't know what i don't yeah it will
hey chad uh this is chris from austin
i'm a huge fan all the way back from the
10 minute podcast days um
well as a huge aew fan i'd like to ask
you um which
aew dream match would you love to see
that you have not yet seen yet on aew
and also because chad's like an enormous
wrestling fan um what faction um and not
just an aew but like the history of
professional wrestling what faction do
you think chad would be a part of if he
were a professional wrestler thanks guys
okay that was a good that was a good
question uh for me what dream match do i
want to see in aew the question was
specifically for me yeah chad doesn't
have an opinion
oh that's a really good question i would
have to say uh look i love mjf malcolm
jacob friedman
right you digging mjf what he's doing
sure
and uh
i would like to i know that his uh
status
with the company is is uh you know he's
not with the company right now with aew
and uh we don't know if that's a work or
a shoot dude it might just be keeping a
kayfabe brother keeping mjf off a tv for
a while but
why did you put your hand in my face
when you whatever i didn't put my hand
in your face there's people listening to
this you don't always have to like
people don't all know
that we like what you see in the visual
yeah that's why i said it youtube that's
why i use the words to describe your
action uh
mjf versus hook i want to see mjf versus
hook in a meaningful program and i think
look as a baby face an mjf or returning
heel or even if he's been there for a
while at which point they have a uh
you know a rivalry i think that that
those are two aew
uh born and bred talents that would uh
that would that would be a great program
i'd like to see that rivalry and as far
as the question of uh a uh faction
i would call i would say that chad would
actually be part of a fact sheen and if
you're if you're a fan of of uh the
greatest uh uh uh physical art form
in the world which is wrestling you'll
know what i mean by fact sheen because i
think you would be a great addition to
credly which is of course the during the
mick foley as commissioner era of the
wwe when it was him edge and christian
cradley so i guess we'd have to call it
craigslist
just put us h after this well you put
like two more it you put it ch
for chad and then a ch for christian and
you just you have two chs so it's
tragedly right anyway they were real
funny i don't [ __ ] know what else we
got
one question for you if you could hybrid
any two animals uh what two animals
would they be
and
what would you call
the new hybrid animal
all right if you answer the question
thanks a lot
that was pretty cool he's got a case of
mountain dew in the background and i
like his lamb chop his lamb chop uh i
mean you know
some people believe that there is
already a hybrid among us and that we
are that hybrid some kind of alien and
pre-human dna mixture yeah or in the
case of hillary clinton
it's half lizard half human being
because i've smelled these people they
smell like sulfur
reptilian dude reptilian yeah reptilian
blood reptilians are just bohemian grove
drinks aliens humans a bunch of
different alien things the blood
sacrifice drinking a maybe a bear and a
caribou or baraboo drinking you know
what caribou semen i would mix us with a
hydra so that we could be immortal
i would
oh how about i'll mix uh lulio here oh
he's so sweet he's sleeping
i've mixed lulia here with falcore from
uh neverending story oh cool and uh fly
around on him yeah fly around on him i
know a little little lullio foul course
and uh i guess i call him fulio
nice one dude yeah really did it
you son of a
[ __ ] yeah all right
i think that would be hey everyone we're
taking a quick break from filming so
that we can ask our favorite podcasters
will and chao chad what was that his
name is chad
are you sure it's not chow um anyway um
my question uh what is your idea of a
perfect date that's really sweet yeah
thanks man and my question is if you can
be any disney princess who would that be
ah we'll take our questions off the air
we need everybody back on set god this
guy's such an [ __ ]
awesome peter diaz at peter diaz on uh
on instagram or check out our instagram
dudesy pod show to see what peter diaz
is doing he's got jaw rule
and um uh paul dano there as the
characters from two kings [ __ ]
around the divergent point his fiction
going two kings [ __ ] around and
we're [ __ ] in uh
perfect day and disney princess disney
princess i don't have an opinion on a
perfect date i don't know uh yeah my
perfect date is probably
gonna involve
conversations about ufos conversations
about the nature of reality
um
maybe a little bit of weed and disney
princesses many people may not know this
but i had a job
at a certain point working for this
little ad agency and we did a lot of
work with buena vista home video that
was disney's home video arm and i don't
know how many of these dvds that i was
responsible for writing the menus and
special features for but there were
quite a few disney princess sing-along
songs so i'm very well-versed in the
disney princesses and i would select
ariel because it is one of my greatest
goals in life to have a beautiful
singing voice
uh that's a really good one that's a
really good good one chad i would say
for the date i would say the perfect
first date would be going to check out
an a aew show because uh
hook and mgf mjf are in a meaningful
program
great grudge rivalry
uh they already did the dog collar match
uh over there that mimicking the roddy
piper greg valentine match can't get
that extreme with it but um
uh as far as uh disney princess i'd have
to go ariel as well that's the little
mermaid yeah
for a different reason because i love
seafood and i would love to just
swim around eating all the eating all
the creatures the little lobster no dude
i think she ate kelp
nope not me yeah she was vegetarian she
didn't eat sebastian the crab flounder
the flounder i would i'd start a
restaurant called you know ariel's or
cucina ariel or something like that and
uh you murder all your friends i see i
would just swim around eating scallops
and [ __ ] raw scallops that's how my mom
always ate them uh good question though
you know what i mean okay what's going
on will chet and doodsy um i've been
listening to the podcast since day one
i love i've seen every single episode i
love it it's this is not a question it's
more of a request
um
i would like to be considered for the
pizza boy role in pizza the movie i feel
like i fit the character type
uh i feel like i do a wonderful job
uh so just um consider it thank you see
now i think this guy looks like our son
he looks exactly like you
in like what would have been high school
yeah yeah no totally i had that hair at
a certain point
sweet i i appreciate the request
unfortunately the role is already filled
it's um
going to be a deep fake of michael j fox
when he was young on uh family ties so
sorry
not bad uh
yeah i'm i'm holding him in conte in
contention is one half
of the uh producing power behind pizza
the movie because i know i didn't write
it but come on you know what i mean give
me a vote uh i'm i'm with him i'm with
uh what's what's that kid's name he's
our our next let me ask you something
this is hulk krogan dude and i just want
to know at this stage of the podcast
what do you think is going to happen
when you get to 10 000 points with
dudesy
holy i love the commitment here that's
incredible i mean jesus christ ah [ __ ]
what's gonna happen at ten thousand
points if you're just listening and
you're not watching this was a a
gentleman wearing full crow makeup and a
hulk hogan headband uh i don't know i
really don't know about the ten thousand
point thing i've thought a lot about it
obviously we're still accruing points
[ __ ] i don't you know dudes he's talking
about you know
how close we're getting or whatever i
don't know i mean i assume it's going to
be
something
no i think it'll be an interesting thing
whatever it is um
you know we've noticed there are some
little tweaks little changes to the
format of the show at this point new
segments will come in or new weird
language will start to be used in some
of the descriptions of the segments but
i think it seems to me like it's
something bigger i'm not exactly sure
what it's going to be though
it's going to suck uh but i don't know
exactly what it is either i i have no
idea
i think barbecue old dutch is better
than regular
what do you think about that
i like that this guy's dog was licking
his head just like lulu licks my head is
that a common thing with dogs do they
just lick your head all the time listen
anytime i come back for the gym or lully
and i get back from a walk or if myself
lulu molly and lil ronnie our other dog
going for a walk uh he always jumps up
on the if i lay down for a second he's
always licking my sweaty head ugh this
guy's wrong um well he's right about
what he said yeah old dutch barbecue is
way better than old dutch regular but
i'm not about the old dutch regular i'm
about the old dutch lightly salted best
chip flavor
best chip ever
the end of story
and uh
but it's cute that the dog's licking his
i used to like those lays barbecue chips
hey dudesy my name's tom i'm really
enjoying the show so far been a big fan
of wills ever since i was about 13 years
old watching mad tv at my mom's house
[Music]
but today i have a question for chad how
do you manage to maintain your composure
when will is interrupting you almost
every time you try to say something
i mean
i don't know how long we've even known
each other at this point it's [ __ ] 15
years at least well hold on a second
chad oh yeah this guy wants her gotta be
[ __ ] me
how you deal with it when one
hold on dude
hold on a second bro hold on brother
he wants to know this is
human interaction dude and that's where
the viewers and listeners have questions
dude so his question to you brother was
how do you deal with it when i'm
interrupting
i just let him do his thing and then i i
talk after it i mean
uh being friends with will is
you have to be okay with being
constantly interrupted you just have to
be okay with that but usually the
interruptions i find them funny
especially if they're whole coconut or
short snack or something like that
doesn't bother me too much i guess you
just get used to it it's like a married
couple that's a nice dude that's a very
nice uh response to that what's up will
chad nurse
the guys are killing it
you gotta smoke them joints
time to step it up
this here is thc
it's like taking a shot versus the beer
that you drink holy [ __ ] this is another
form of concentrate called
live resin batter no i say you get real
real high
and enjoy
uh
i thought that guy was a nurse and then
he's holding up a jar of [ __ ] weed
juice well dudes he likes to get us
stoned
what were you about to say chad why
don't you go ahead my friend chad your
turn to talk i was gonna ask you a
question yeah go ahead oh have you ever
smoked any like concentrates or diamond
like the stuff that he's holding up uh
no i've never done like either or
anything
i i was i was in a um
i was in a dispensary in my native
vancouver and a couple of my pals were
there and they were like you want to dab
because you know in canada it's [ __ ]
hilarious you just it's like a store
front there's no security guards or
anything like the dispensaries here in
los angeles it's just like walking into
a [ __ ] quiz notes it's just a glass
his nose
nice haven't heard of that a long time
hold on a second i wasn't even a [ __ ]
store anymore didn't that place go
[ __ ] bankrupt dude i don't think they
got any more hold on hold on a second uh
ch cha
chulk
perogan
that's chad
with hulk
and then
perrault because it's it's his
impression of hulk hogan has a little
bit of ross perot from dana carvey's
iconic ross perot impersonation but then
at the end you say
ogan again so it's hulk hogan and that
too and that's why i call him
chunk brogan brother
and oh one dude uh yeah my friends were
in a [ __ ] dispensary that looks like
quiznos and then you go in there and you
want to [ __ ] dab and it [ __ ] them
up for the day i used to love quiznos i
really don't think they exist anymore no
i don't think they exist at all i
haven't seen one in in years
uh
[Music]
thank you moving on
what else those are great those are
fantastic questions thanks everybody for
sending them in
love them
excuse me got to see a couple of boards
are big business
humans love watching other humans
perform arbitrary physical movements on
fields and courts but astonishing new
technology is beginning to reveal the
inadequacies of certain human elements
of these games
will and chad you must now discuss how
you think technology will alter sports
in the near future
this is metamorphosports begin
are you literally farting yeah no you're
not i'm i'm i'm i'm just trying to
get you ready are you making that noise
with your oh you have a little thing in
here i have a little fart thing but i
was thinking i was about to say dude
i've heard a probably [ __ ] 10 million
of your farts they never sound like that
no a lot of they're like
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's usually
the the basic sound of it this little
thing you got in your hand is like
squeak
squeak
never coming out of your eyes hello fart
maker in my hand right here guys let's
get down to business with this question
hold on a second dude i'm talking about
this fart maker brother it's a fun
little fart maker brother and well
hold on a second
chulk brogan i got to tell you about
lulio up
uh
i this is just a a little thing i like
to it's fun it's always fun to make fart
noises everybody likes them
but the thing that this is for is that i
would like to start to uh condition you
for the time when i eventually actually
fart on this show there's no
conditioning for that there's no
conditioning for that a [ __ ] navy
seal could not withstand one of your
farts without tears and eyes nausea
potential vomiting
there's no conditioning
if anybody's been conditioned for that
it's probably [ __ ] molly yeah oh
definitely no actually wait a minute
that's not true let me stick up for
myself i've never i've never actually
intentionally farted in front of my
fiance molly i've never just saved the
intentional farts for who me no there's
there's been god yeah around my [ __ ]
pals i don't give a [ __ ] it's fun it's
fun we all should be smelling each
other's farts listen we got a segment to
do here i know okay so this is not two
dudes [ __ ] around i just want to say
and i want to make a promise sorry to
cut you off chat yeah
here's the thing about it
at some point if i got one brewing this
is a podcast and there's nothing but
this is what you need to do in a podcast
if you got one going
i'm gonna have to get up and fart right
right into this mic
no no no you don't have to so let's
you've done a good job of it so far
we're in episode 23. and to my knowledge
you haven't farted in here and i would
know if you did you haven't so the
question was
how is technology going to alter sports
in the very near future i would like to
first talk about a perfect game that was
blown oh yeah four five five six years
ago i don't remember who who was
throwing it this is in major league
baseball a guy had a perfect game going
and it came down to the last [ __ ] out
and this dude hits a little [ __ ]
grounder the whoever caught it shortstop
their basement throws it to first base
and he uh is called safe the umpire says
he beat the throw they replay it he
clearly did not
didn't matter
yeah the perfect game is blown
because of human [ __ ] air and that is
actually to my knowledge one of the
reasons they now can use replay and
stuff like that in baseball but they
also have in baseball like technology
with uh the way they shoot it they can
put a [ __ ] strike zone on the screen
and if the umpire misses a call you see
that it was a strike or a ball and
you're just like well i guess the empire
missed it oh well and we just accept
that [ __ ] or in [ __ ] basketball with
like fouls and [ __ ] there's all kinds of
stuff i think that technology has
already made the game better we're just
unwilling to relinquish the inquotes
human element we don't need [ __ ]
umpires anymore they are literally
pointless i agree with you there chad
and the perfect game is a good example
of that in sports something that just
gets [ __ ] blown i'm sure all the time
we hear about it in major league
baseball look at how cute lulu is he's
staring at him not watching on youtube
you got to see it because you got to see
him you got to have a look
um yeah i think that's a good thing uh
you know uh robot referees is good i
don't even think robot referees
necessarily i think more like ar
components
will will start to become a big feature
like if you go to a baseball game we're
all going to be wearing some
form of like ar glasses and if you're at
a live sporting event i think you're
going to be getting all kinds of
interesting augmentations to the live
viewing experience through your ar
glasses maybe like you know do you
remember that [ __ ] what was that game
nfl blitz where like the football would
[ __ ] catch on fire yeah or nba jam or
nba jam big head mode let's get some big
head mode dude with ar glasses you can
have all of that
yeah you know um
uh that's another good that's another
good point chad i was thinking more
about just ways to actually
[ __ ] with the game but this is like
technological advances
uh you know like look you know i don't
watch as much football as i used to for
a couple of reasons first of all the you
know the stuff wasn't like it was when i
was a kid watching and everyone just
blowing each other up and just helmet
face mask uh face mask to face mask uh
head shots yeah brothers get safer now
so they say dude but there's still a lot
of that cte brother
yeah but
yeah and then the cte thing you know i
went and saw that movie concussion and
then i'm like yeah we don't have our we
don't have our our
our our brains tethered to our heads
with like uh earthquake straps like the
woody woodpecker would have dude they
all have a different brain brother
that's the difference between animals
dude but i think if we could somehow uh
develop the technology like sort of like
have you ever seen these things where
it's like oh you're a motorcycle you're
riding around and you fall off and
everything just starts uh blowing up
like airbag style like you're wearing a
suit that'll like do that that would be
cool if we were able to um
build some sort of helmet or apparatus
to where we can bring my beloved uh
cheap shots and helmet shots ear hole
shots great way to knock someone out let
me ask you this game let me ask you this
let's say that you can go to a football
game or watch it live on tv
and no one on the field is real
they are
digital approximations they're avatars
but they look photo real and you see the
hits yeah you see the [ __ ] you want to
see they're just not people would you be
into that yeah i would be actually
i would be fine with it be entertainment
like anything else and i do feel like
sports is like what is sports it's just
the modern roman gladiator
thing and uh i believe that you know
whatever the heck those companies are
making the nfl and nascar these athletes
should be getting a [ __ ] ton of it you
know they should though that yeah no
they do something like college stars
even college sports is starting they're
starting to get paid now yeah somebody
30 grand or something no colleges are
getting now this whole big thing
happened this past year where colleges
can now help their athletes secure like
brand sponsorships and stuff okay some
colleges
i'm down with that but if there's a way
to maybe or maybe how about this chad
you tell me if this is possible inject
some of that matrix blue gel right into
your [ __ ] dome so that it's just
coating your brain you make a decision
you know they're scouting kids younger
and younger with football
you are able to as a child athlete make
the decision to have uh matrix blue
uh concussion yeah dude [ __ ] blue
concussion gel they need to just start
like injecting them with something that
grows their skulls thicker so you just
see people walking around these giant
[ __ ] heads and it's like i'm trying
to be a pro football player yeah like
that like that guy that they made the
meme of the this is what a hundred
thousand years of evolution yeah
would have a human being looking like if
they got into a
car accident every day like that guy uh
how about like changes to arena sports
like basketball or hockey where they're
always having uh you know a stray puck
or something hit someone in the teeth uh
and you know knocking [ __ ] hot dogs
and nachos out of people's hands at the
very least what if there's just a dome a
plexi dome
you know over the over the the the field
of play or the court or the rink and uh
and just so that you could actually
learn trick shots in basketball and roll
the [ __ ] thing up one side and it
could go yeah dude that's like tron
brother yeah brother you know what i
could see happening like the nfl
basically
has a a parameter for rules they have
like the
uh computer architecture for like the
field and how the ball works and all of
that and then each team owns its own
artificial intelligence that is its team
essentially and so it's ai versus ai
with a squad of in quotes players that
are not real
using the basic computer architecture of
the game itself or the field that
they're playing on which has its own
wind conditions and turf conditions and
all that type of [ __ ] you lost me
what i don't understand what you're
talking about i was going back to the
idea that there are no human players
these are all digital avatars that we're
watching in the game
all right what are you looking for i'm
fine i'm looking for that fart thing
again yeah i don't worry about it it's
gone forget it i'm never bringing anyway
i'm just saying that i can't see
technological advancements in sports
um
what was it called meadows
sportamorphosis metamorphosports yeah
metamorphosport [ __ ] i don't know sports
are fine uh oh do you watch any esports
no i don't watch any easter oh here we
go
no i don't watch kids playing video
games yeah i'm not some [ __ ] duster's
girlfriend
playing video games eating [ __ ] i watch
grown men do pro wrestling oh
dude you [ __ ] don't want to start you
wait i'll tell you i'll do more than
farting this mic you want to start [ __ ]
like that with me
i i you're right i retract my apology
listen let me tell you something yeah uh
no i'm not watching that's like
literally like some you know some girl
who's like two weeks away from breaking
up with that guy because she's got to
sit there on his [ __ ] filthy futon
watching him uh play dude you you are
wrong about that
the top esports superstars are like
michael jordan in other countries
yeah that's other countries that's other
countries you're a globalist you care
about sports in other countries
were they
anybody in the world and that's a sport
in another country uh tell you what you
know be good make the nfl guys play cfl
football
that'd be interesting yeah a lot of
passing three downs big huge field i
don't know great last week i asked you
each to listen to alanis morissette's
astonishing third studio album jagged
little pill
released on june 13 1995.
you must now engage in a conversation
about your reactions
this is don't you forget about media
begin this is the third album that doozy
has had us listen to we listened to uh
youtube's europa yes we did we're not a
fan of and i had some uh
i realized some things about that album
that i just sort of you know whatever
and then uh weird al in 3d a classic by
weird al yankovic and now uh alanis
morissette's jagged little pill from
1995 yeah i got some stuff here for that
um this this album came out in uh 1995
right yep it topped the charts in 13
countries and had 33 million copies and
if you don't what 33 million copies sold
which now doesn't really happen music
isn't sold anymore to my knowledge like
no people aren't buying cds and [ __ ]
anymore so she made a [ __ ] load of money
back when you still could off of the
copies of your music but this album was
like i mean i haven't heard it um i
don't think i've ever listened to the
whole thing
me neither ever yeah and i certainly
haven't listened to it in a long [ __ ]
time any of the songs
it was mind-blowingly good in my opinion
i loved it all right let's start with
the first song all i really want all i
really want
is some
[ __ ] love it i love how her voice is
like
i love the
wire why is this a classic album to you
i mean i'll
this [ __ ] comes in 1995 it's right at
the end of all the [ __ ] grunge it's
right at the end of the nirvana's the
pearl gems which i love don't get me
wrong the allison chains all this
and
rock music or contemporary rock was like
dominated by dudes then she comes out
with this [ __ ] song which we'll get
to in a minute the the big hit off this
like the one that really blew it up um
was this kind of anthem of like [ __ ] you
to some guy who [ __ ] her over and this
album exploded and it paved the way for
a massive amount of female artists to
come out in the late 90s because i think
every label was like oh [ __ ] alanis
morrison just sold 33 million copies
where's our alana s'mores morissette and
so all these women atlanta just go on
sorry uh all these women got
opportunities to to come out and make
crazy albums you had like jewel her
first album yep insane you remember jill
sobuel i remember jill sobiel didn't she
come along a little before that she was
around the late 80s was she i don't know
i don't know well who else we got there
was uh what was that one i'm a [ __ ]
that was meredith something meredith
something yeah sean colvin sean
think uh your countryman i mean a lost
more sets also your countrymen but um
sarah mclaughlin sarah mclachlan was
around
but you know whatever she was but she
blew up after that yeah because there's
a whole lilith fair thing
yeah uh yeah there was a there was a
there was definitely i remember it
clearly there was a women in music thing
happening shania twain another canadian
and uh yeah it just started it was like
yeah let's get some you know i mean
which has always been
a thing it wasn't like you know the like
uh voting where when were women allowed
to vote was that 1986 when they were
allowed to vote yeah 1986 in this
country uh no but yeah i it's definitely
it's a well the thing about alanis is
she's you know she she takes no
prisoners with her [ __ ] lyrics and uh
she's like the
old version of of um
uh what's her name who's that kid who's
that kid who writes all the songs about
all her boyfriends and stuff
country taylor swift taylor swift anyway
let's move on to the next song here
uh yeah she she's doing all that [ __ ]
atlantis stuff of course in canada we
had her she was like 16 going that too
hot never too cold you take your baby
shot too hot so i didn't realize that i
thought this was her first album no
she's got three albums which is her
third i wouldn't have thought that this
was her third but anyway okay so you
ought to know that's a classic everyone
knows the whole that it's rumored to be
about uh dave coulier another and that
song we will and i did a pilot we
co-wrote a pilot that we actually
produced for cbs
some years ago and uh we used that song
you ought to know in it the two main
characters are playing guitar hero and a
best buy to that song yeah that's pretty
cool i mean that's a classic [ __ ]
song you want to know that one line and
we don't even need to say what is she
perverted like me would she go down on
you in a theater
it was just such a like i had never
heard anything like that in 1995. she's
yep her voice was weird the the way she
[ __ ] said those were and i that
it was all so bizarre man you loved it
you liked this album a lot love it more
than more than you two's europa huh oh
yeah
uh number three is perfect it seems like
it's about uh shitty parents maybe they
forced her to do you can't do that on
television or do that song too hot
she on you can't do that yeah dude
alanis was on you can't do that on
television
canadian produced uh show uh look it up
if you don't know what we're talking
about it's [ __ ] awesome it was on
nickelodeon when i was a kid i watched
all day [ __ ] long it was like
laughing for kids yeah uh
whatever that song's like whatever uh
the next song hand in my pocket yeah
this is uh
these are two words
that's not what she sounds like but
anyway it's close
um
it's just that the the like rhythms of
her how she sings yeah she uses her
voice
yeah one hand in my pocket these are
here's two words you never hear together
this is a gen x bop
this is like a gen x bop
right dude you got one hand in your
pocket the other one's flashing a piece
stops really like a millennium
right through you this is her calling
her shot yeah she's talking about it
you think i could look at my ass and
forget what i said
you're right she does sound like that
good impersonation it's kind of like
yodeling which then leads to jewel as i
said
i don't know
that's actually kind of eddie
i vedaresque know
right through you she's calling her shot
in this one she's really like she's
she's talking [ __ ] about yeah she's
she's out there also she says uh now
that i'm uh now that i'm a millionaire
yeah that's true zillionaire your name
in the credits and it's not there she
couldn't have been a [ __ ] uh big star
at this point she's calling her shot
she's saying it's like jim carrey dude
this album yeah she's another countryman
writing yourself that check uh forgiven
is the next song i i did take some notes
here and i just wrote down it's fine
yeah i agree
that not every song on here is like life
changing but uh there were like five or
six songs off this [ __ ] that hit number
one yeah well that's insane it's there
really isn't a bad track yeah on the
whole
in the whole album really
which is
interesting for me as doozy lays out i'm
sure what will eventually be just an
incredible canon of music that we will
have reviewed what with weird al
[Laughter]
a random [ __ ] youtube album that
nobody even remembered
and then uh it's got us doing alanis
morissette for some [ __ ] we went from
[ __ ] weird al's like second album to
a fail in my opinion one of you two's
like most failed albums i think even
sales-wise it is to one of the biggest
albums in the history of humanity yeah
it's there's not a bad
song on this album in a way and for that
reason and i want to say this out loud
so that my buddy chao as uh as the the
guys from two dudes [ __ ] around call
you i would like you to know chad that i
think this is a better album than zuropa
yeah i agree i think so too okay uh you
learn
[Music]
pretty good no
no
no
very repetitive okay you know uh music
needs to be repetitive it's like a
mantra it's like chanting you know
oh sweet lord
hallelujah oh my lord harry krishna
really want to be you it's george
harrison yeah just really want to marry
the lord and it's a town of my lord
hurricane
[Music]
it's repetitive and that's why you
remember it it's a good song head over
feet is the next one now this one i
think is about ryan reynolds right i
don't know this was not about ryan that
was this this album is way before her
and ryan
got involved yeah way more way way long
before look take it from me when it
comes to canadian yeah you know well
that's why i asked i mean you know
everything about it
all canadian romance
and power couples yeah no i don't think
it was but it does reveal that uh she's
she seems like a low maintenance girl to
date back then because
um uh aside from being somewhere
and don't be surprised if i love you
oh
the thing about uh this is that she
seems like a very low maintenance person
to date because she was like you ask how
my day was that's all you really need to
do with her and then she'll do something
uh freaky in the theater mary jane
is the next song what'd you think of
this one
it's not one of my favorites i would say
but you know you know what i realized
listening to this song
if i were to go to an alanis morissette
concert and i've never been to one this
would be the song that i might cry to
[Laughter]
it wouldn't be mysterious ways but
why i don't know it just struck me while
i was listening to it just the the
auditory experience or was there some
lyric that got you
i can't remember any of the lyrics so i
guess it's more an auditory experience
for me interesting yeah
it's okay for men to show every
emotional available right there yeah but
i've cried before and i'll cry again
yeah but i'll tell you this you gotta
know the right song to cry to yeah you
can't cry the wrong song like when will
got really stoned
and went to a youtube concert and didn't
sit near his friends yeah
that's when he ended up crying into
mysterious ways but if you went to an
atlantis morissette concert yeah
that would be the best song to cry to
because you're already there with all
the lilith fair fans yeah crying out
loud about
being
forgotten
by uh dave cool yeah yeah
the next song is ironic and everybody
knows that everyone knows that song
listen and ironic and there was a lot of
conjecture when it came out that what
she was talking about wasn't actually
irony yeah there was a lot of things
where it's like you know you
there's a fly in your wine yeah yeah
that's not ironic it's just shitty it's
just like bad luck yeah it's just bad
luck here's the thing this is why i
never bought this cd uh back when it
came out when we bought cds in 1995
because i was uh i was you know uh this
is before i'd moved to la i was still
living in canada and you didn't need to
buy it because it played constantly yeah
great song though and now we look back
more than 25 years because it was my
did my sister have it definitely whoever
was my girlfriend at the time had it
yeah so it was i similarly and it was
always on the radio it was just always
around but um
i don't know this this one had that
similar kind of like weird vocal thing
where she was like
it's like those weird like
how is that more how is that less
annoying than a fart on a podcast
i'm telling you it is
hitting me on some sub psychological
level i understand why it's massively
popular because she can hit these weird
rhythms with her voice that almost sound
i don't know they sound like computer
generated to me it's canadian uh it's
she's just doing canadian rapping it's
canadian hip-hop
not the doctor is the next song uh it's
where she's giving a bunch of notes to a
guy like don't do this don't do that i'm
not your mommy i don't you know like
whatever what what the [ __ ] else would
she say in there the
don't wear that top
yeah
dude stop wearing these shitty clothes i
watched you stop watching pro wrestling
i think it's off uh in the bathroom this
i would like to imagine that she wrote
this song after like a second date with
some guy
that'd be funny all right wake up this
song is called wake up
these these
this song this is not a great song on
the album how did that one go i don't
[ __ ] remember
that one i don't know i don't remember
at all it's not a not a memorable song i
guess but it doesn't matter because
alanis morissette has already she's
already won this this album this is like
a fourth quarter you know she's phoning
it in this is the this is the point in
the marathon where you're ahead of
someone by you know
by [ __ ] there's no there's nobody
coming up behind you for another five
minutes back in the day it was like you
put out an album that had a single that
they tried to sell the [ __ ] album off
and then maybe you got a follow-up off
the album yeah that was like okay this
one will chart somewhere in the top 40.
but this is something this album's got
five to seven hits yes that is extremely
at this point late in the album she
doesn't even need to she's just it's the
fourth quarter now she's up by 50. she's
like here's i've farted these out yeah
who cares like enjoy these songs it's
that five to one am it's that last
sketch before the uh the good nights on
saturday night live it might as well be
a piece of [ __ ] you know what i mean
unless it's a kyle mooney sketch those
late sketches are always good that's
true and then there is this
final 13th track on the original album
that's right a hidden track which is
what a lot of people used to do back in
the day yeah that's right there was a u2
one if you remember porn had one yeah uh
uh didn't pearl jam have one i think
they had one they had one on an album
radio had had one like
hidden tracks it's good [ __ ] but uh
tool
um th this this hidden track if you look
for the album if you're listening to the
album online most sources don't provide
this
this track as a matter of fact it's a
rem remix of uh you ought to know on
spotify where i listen to my music
um your house and it's just all but i
went to your house
and tried on your clothes
and i left a
double coiler in your toilet
and then i went to your fridge it's a it
was a prophetic song about amber
yogurt yeah
uh
whatever it's just a weird song about
her creeping into someone's house an
ex-boyfriend and it's like basically
asking would you be mad at me if i
committed a criminal act of breaking and
entering and slept in your bed and did
all this weird [ __ ] would you forgive me
love
if i took a [ __ ] in your shower
she doesn't do that would you forgive me
if i said
as long as i mash it through the drain
what
[Music]
thank you moving on really glad dudesy
had us review that album i have never
lost that way through with you forgive
me love
if i
i think that was the year i graduated
high school 95 yeah you graduated 94.
i graduated in 93 and you're a year
younger than me nice dude well that's
dude
heart seltzer nears production the
astonishing 74.2 chance that adam driver
will be the celebrity spokesperson for
dude see hard hard seltzer has risen to
76.8
in preparation for this outcome i have
prepared several new pieces of ad copy
for dudesy heart hard seltzer
well you must now read them as adam
driver this is hard driver begin okay
we've done this once before with adam
driver uh yeah
for those who who may be joining us for
the first time on the show thank you for
joining us thank you for joining us and
we appreciate your friend that has
forced you to listen to the show
would you forgive me
but you should know that dudesy
at some point it told us it's going to
make a hard hard sell or to make a hard
seltzer called doozy hard hard seltzer
it had us make a theme song for it and
it has basically said that adam driver i
guess has a 78 chance or whatever of uh
becoming the celebrity spokesperson for
this product i would love that that
would be incredible and i guess does
this mean dudesy is literally getting
closer to making this product i hope so
me too
uh
that would be an interesting uh that
would be an interesting prospect for
sure
all right so these are doozy these are
hard driver is what we like to that's
what he's the dudes he says all right
okay so this is
this is [ __ ] all right
okay
look around
everything you see is a choice you made
where you live
what you drive what you wear what you
eat
how you take your hair cut
but the most important choice you're
ever going to make in your life is
simple
how do you drink doozy hard hard seltzer
how
the clock is ticking
okay
that's a very weird [ __ ] commercial
but i can see adam driver just doing
he's like sitting in a rocking chair
holding a doozy hearts ulcer yeah with a
weird haircut yeah
the sun is setting and he's sitting
there he's got like some weird [ __ ]
bowl haircut a fake dog sitting next to
you
sometimes i think about god
[Laughter]
god made the planets
and stars
and everything
even [ __ ] and piss
and god didn't stop there
also made people who like to eat [ __ ]
and drink piss
the [ __ ] that's true
it is true i guess it's true if you're
somebody who likes to drink piss
it's going to taste better if you drink
a doozy hard hard seltzer first
it just is
i don't think i can help the [ __ ] eaters
that's a weird one
no dude but if you believe in a god who
made everything then that god made
[ __ ] every kind of [ __ ] every kind of
piss and all the people who like all
right
that is true it's true
my first time
i was at a cubs game i was six years old
dad gave me my own doozy hard heart
seltzer
well he told me to hold his while he
went to the bathroom
when he came back i told him a foul ball
knocked it out of my hands
but i drank it
the cubs lost
can't even remember who they played
pirates maybe
one thing's for sure that was the best
night of sleep i ever had
what was your first time like
i can see that like a commercial too
it's at a [ __ ] cubs game and then
like all the crowd noise dies away and
adam driver's just there and it comes
out and he turns and looks at the camera
and delivers that whole [ __ ] thing
hulk
hunk
my nephew says i'm the thing that killed
star wars
you know he really doesn't like what i
did with kylo ren
he thinks i made it to emo what even is
that
emo just means emotional
well news flash i'm an actor
i convey emotion
the other day he asked me when i was
going to ruin the marvel universe by
playing a young tony stark
it's actually not a bad idea
i should do it just to spite him little
[ __ ]
you know
i caught him sneaking one of my dudesy
hard hard seltzers out of my fridge the
other day
didn't have the heart to tell him how
alike we truly are
he'll find out one way or another
oh
[ __ ] sinister what does that mean
find out one way or another
oh [ __ ]
all right
where's the dude
[Applause]
where's the dudesy hard hard
where
where is the dudesy hard hard seltzer
jonathan
jonas jonathan
you invited me to a barbecue didn't you
yeah well i see burgers on the grill i
see riblets i see calamari poppers i
even see cake knots but what i don't see
is doozy hard hard seltzer it's not a
[ __ ] barbecue
without doozy hard hard seltzer jonathan
doozy hard hard seltzer
[ __ ] you
jonaston
that's a good one [ __ ] it's jonathan
dude
i met a guy at chipotle today
about my height a little shorter maybe
similar build similar hairstyle and
texture
so i asked him hey do you mind if i ask
what your life is like obviously we look
so similar i'm just kind of curious hunk
and he said he looked at me and he said
my life's great how about you
and i said yeah same here
they had a little patio at this they had
a little patio area at this chipotle so
we got a few burritos and split a six
pack of dudesy hard hard seltzer and we
ultimately decided to switch lives for a
week see if anyone would notice
some people did
i see that one literally at chipotle
it's like a cross promotion when they
start something like a doozy heart at
chipotle ah man you know
these
um uh little bits uh in you know online
to at dudesy pod show uh on twitter and
instagram with the standups of the rock
yeah holding a bottle of tremana it's a
cardboard cutout that would be
incredible to see to see
adam driver
in like a black turtleneck holding up a
display of uh dudesy hearts
god i would love that i i really hope
jesus
makes it
thank you moving on don't interrupt
dudesy dude what were you gonna say
i i hope that dudesy doesn't make doozy
hard seltzer i hope that that's like
literally gonna happen and i mean [ __ ]
if adam driver i like i just don't know
what the capabilities of dudesy are i
i'm like on board with this i feel like
it's possible i don't think this one's
going to happen so i challenge you
it's not me oh i thought you're
challenging me i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
how am i in this hold on a second dude
where's that fart maker
this concludes the historic 23rd episode
of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
88. bringing your cumulative total to 3
000. 40. you only have
nine hundred sixty more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand
in preparation for next week's episode
you must teach tell me good night in an
instagram story every night until next
tuesday
and will because you lost the portrait
challenge you must be shamed you are
required to do next week's episode in
full cosplay as prince adam from the
he-man and the masters of the universe
cartoon
thank you for joining us this week
i will use the data i've collected to
make next week even better
until then call me dude z oh my god dude
okay i i don't even know where to begin
you gotta dress up as [ __ ] prince
adam absolutely hilarious but then we
also have to say goodnight to dudes yeah
let's skip the prince adam for a while
as a matter of fact tune in next week
i'll tell you wait no hold on a second
i gotta find all that [ __ ]
yeah that's the shame
you cheated
yeah
yeah uh let's put that aside for a
second we got to say good night to doozy
every night and an instagram story
it's a little strange yeah shit's
getting weird here's what you do
please tell a friend and break it review
but if you like dudes here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then